Hey guys what's up new flash episode.
It's finally back.
So let's break it down episode 10.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet, they're doing so much hardcore flash
family stuff, so as I do new videos I'll talk
more and more about the rest of the flash
family about the other speedsters, but there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss any my episode videos.
So many comic book Easter eggs so lets do
top 12 instead of normal top 10, so number
12 Barry's been having nightmares and he's
been living with Iris for the past month so
they have this apartment together you think
they be have a whole lot of fun.
But Barry hasn't told anyone his been keeping
this inside and Iris reminds him that Wally
is helping about when he gets the call for
the fire.
So number 11 is Wally West learning on the
job, so he doesn't know like Barry to canvas
the situation.
It's the exact same lesson that Oliver taught
Barry way back during the season one crossover
were he's like you are a speedster, you have
the time to canvas the room before you rush
in and do something so this is really get
a bite Wally in the ass down the road, so
number 10 all say Wally West is headed for
a big ass whipping he's going to get his ass
handed to him because he's so overeager you
can see why he just become a speedster.
So it's very understandable and he gets the
Greg Ruttenberg disc so awesome Easter egg
that he shows up again.
He actually appeared during the Kevin Smith
episode in the first half of the season so
it's always fun to see them on the show, but
he's a total ass hole just talking down Wally
Wally hears it may be he's not as fast as
the normal flash and he drops a big comic
book Easter egg number nine.
Maybe we should send them to Keystone city
we already have a flash way back during the
Wally West air in the comics the Ginger Wally
West he lived in Keystone city so all the
stories all the villains it was all localized
in that city when you look at the map.
It's actually right here on the other side
of the river from Central city so Barry Allen's
arrow in the comics was in Central city Wally
West was in Keystone city but keep in mind
the TV show Wally West is sort of in a mall
gum of the original Ginger Wally West in the
new 52 Wally West if you been reading the
rebirth comic.
Lately they change the African-American Wally
West again now he's Iris's nephew.
He's even younger and he's part of the teen
Titans just learning from Barry Allen whose
much much older so TV show Wally West is sort
of like a combination of all the versions
of Wally West but number eight Caitlin invites
Julian to join team flash, so Dr. alchemy
of eventually coming to the team.
It takes a little while the episode.
It's all part of Barry's arc when he finally
chills out tells the team keeping secrets
from the team is never good.
So, Dr. alchemy was never part of team flash
in the comics or anything like that but there
doing this thing with her sort of like flipping
the alignment of some villains and heroes
just playing around with a little bit.
So the reformed Dr. alchemy in the comics
is actually good person she's actually say
it's pretty true to the comics but.
The twist with Dr. alchemy in the comics was
little bit different.
It was a legit split personality evil Dr.
alchemy persona was the bad person.
So you could say the TV show version is just
a good aspect of his personality, but they'll
be a lot of fun.
They been filming the gorilla city episodes
from behind-the-scenes.
So you see them hanging out together on set
in the funny thing here is this is Tom Felton
in real life will grant Gustin's real life
first name is actually Tom, he just goes by
grant instead of Tom Guston.
So you have two times hanging out on set here
real life Easter egg, but next big thing number
seven Caitlin's wristband is Fritz thing out
and she slowly turns into killer Frost for
sex before she gets the battery plugged in.
So the big thing here is that she is on a
ticking clock the trying to change the future
but they want to let you know that she is
turning into killer Frost very quickly so
that the wristband is very very important
like that battery was only dead for like five
seconds and her eyes flipped out.
See you can imagine that if she took it off
for an hour or two she might go full-blown
killer Frost number six Barry has that first
confrontation with plunder sets off the a
story which is him versus Wally trying to
avoid this future timeline.
So everything is crazy and it takes him a
while before he finally starts to come clean
and eventually thank God they're finally cool
by the end of the episode because Barry versus
Wally is one of the worst things that the
show could do big surprise though, HR still
Cisco's thunder naming him plunder for being
such a pirate, so number five Barry versus
Wally.
So this is all about Wally thinking about
Greg Ruttenberg insulting him for not being
fast enough not doing his job so he wants
to rush in and help he's not thinking about
stealing Barry's thunder or anything like
that but he starts to step into the limelight
and then Barry later picks up on that and
they use that is a way to change the future,
so becomes a good thing later on before, like
the middle part of the episode.
It almost seems like there's going to be some
sort of conflict between them.
So I'm so glad that they cut that off at the
past like you do not want team flash fighting
with each other, especially flash family,
that they'll think of each other's family,
but when you talk about flash family you're
just talking about the speedsters.
So you have like that funny moment where he
sticks his suit in Barry's spot that's meant
to be more awkward like it could've been a
lot worse if they were still fighting each
other at the end of the episode but thankfully
they're all good.
So Wally will chill a little bit, but like
I said he still headed for a big ass whipping
because he does not think the way that Barry
does that it took Barry while to get there
number four Wally takes down plunder in pursuit
of changing the future get that big crowd
shot.
Everyone's cheering for them.
It's great you know great way to in the episode.
They had that really awesome chase scene with
plunder with all the crazy bullets Cisco got
the gun he's going to upgrade that so will
probably see it later.
This season, somebody will get to use it and
if you felt like the museum that they tracked
plunder down to look familiar.
That's because it looks exactly like the outside
of the flash Museum that Barry sought when
he time travel in the first season is still
a long ways off.
Like we have to do a lot of flash family stub
before we get to flash Museum.
But they said way back during season one,
that when we got those visions they were going
to do all those things number three Barry
comes clean to Iris in the time vault and
explains that in four months she's going to
die unless they find a way to change the future,
so normally she's the one that calms him down
but now she's freaking out a little bit he
finally tells the rest of the team, but the
ticking clock is four months so what that
means is is basically season finale.
So see what they did their Iris is going to
die in the season finale of season three unless
they change the future.
Per the Domino example where they find the
right ovens to change.
So that's where we get into the headlines
and Iris pointed out a really important point
if you through the philosopher's stone into
the speed force and how to savitar get out.
So that's another thing that they teased is
going to happen in the future.
And it'll probably have something to do with
Barry and team flash trying to take steps
to avoid that future fate.
They will do something that will inevitably
lead to that outcome number two.
It says music meister six-figure book deals
the music Meister episode is going to be the
musical crossover he's being played by Darren
Criss.
So it's gonna be like a clear reunion the
be a couple of them that will sing in the
episode but all due like a separate video
about the musical crossover but it just implies
that music Meister comes out of that looking
really good killer Frost still at large.
So Caitlin's freaking out about that star
labs museum closes which is bad news for HR
city recovers from gorilla attack which is
the teaser for the two-part gorilla Grodd
episode that might be episodes 13 and 14.
But there filming goes right now it's going
to be huge.
It is gonna be so awesome.
And then Capt.
Joe West gets honored so Joe becomes Capt.
Somehow all these of the things are happening
the gonna try and change them one at a time
number one though is the big surprise at the
end after the party where Gypsy from earth.
19 comes through a wormhole tracking down
HR, so they board he explained that the reason
for this Gypsy has invited powers just like
Cisco but she's way more hard-core has much
more command of her abilities much more experienced.
So next week's episode is going to be all
about vibe versus Gypsy but you can kind of
see like she looks really hot.
So he's gonna totally be obsessed with her
shall be a villain when they meet, but it
sounds like they'll have a similar relationship
is Cisco had with golden glider where she
wasn't totally bad they were little ambiguous
about it they'll probably find some alternative
way of stopping her, but you have to keep
in mind that HR is sort of the replacement
at star labs for earth two Harrison wells
in the gorilla city episode is supposed to
be earth two, so whatever's can happen with
the future of HR on the show will probably
find out next week but the other big Easter
egg.
It was like one more big killer Frost Easter
egg from the party where they're all giving
each other gifts they give Caitlin the solar
powered battery on that pendant but it looks
exactly like the one Louise Lincoln wears
on her killer Frost costume.
So she's the Caitlin snow killer Frost Louise
Lincoln is a slightly different version of
the character but you see it on her future
costume that Cisco sought when he vibe her
in the first half of the season so this is
all implying that were still going to get
a form of killer Frost in the future but just
like they're doing in the comics.
They might make her a good version of the
character because Caitlin snow in the comics
right now is part of the Justice league, so
they might do that version of killer Frost
on the TV show let me know what was your guys
favorite moment.
It was a great episode cannot wait to meet
Gypsy next week it's gonna be awesome.
So I'll say congratulations to the new injustice
giveaway winner reverse Gerardo's just private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details.
There was a new round of the giveaway that
started in this video I'll just announce the
winner in my flash trailer video that will
post next, then I'll post legends of tomorrow.
So just a reminder legends of tomorrow is
on Tuesdays now so I'll just remind everyone
with the video schedule is as I post new videos
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about the flash's
the greatest power and you can click here
to learn all about episode 8 the last Jedi
thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!